ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata dopo il
successo enorme che la ricetta di bacon
ha avuto abbiamo deciso di prendere un
pochino di consigli da parte vostra e di
seguire un'altra ricetta che va alla
grande nei fast food sto parlando del
chicken mcnuggets 61 cm ragazzi i
folletti prima di partire col
procedimento vorrei inoltre ringraziare
nostro cugino che ci dà la possibilità
di cucinare all'interno del suo cugino
per arredare sempre in maniera
impeccabile questo posto e adesso
abbiamo anche una meravigliosa e carta
da parati con delle scimmie che hanno
dei nomi che non ricordo finiti questi
ringraziamenti di ripartire subito con
gli ingredienti per fare i chicken
mcnuggets per prima cosa serve del pollo
offerta speciale della cipolla tritata
sale e questo fondamentalmente quello
che serve per fare il poletto in se poi
per l'imperatore invece avremmo bisogno
di un sacco di altre cose che sono latte
un ufo amido di mais acqua
frizzantissima farina olio per friggere
non so che ha aperto questa roba al
contrario mi sento come le patatine
fritte che apre patatine fritte o
ammazzerei al contrario la prima se
faremo e preparare il pollo interno
quindi questa roba qui possiamo
toglierla adesso bene ora che non ci
abbiamo più in mezzo ai piedi possiamo
lavorare o abbiamo preso ispirazione per
fare questa ricetta da dal mac è la
soprattutto un canale che ringraziamo e
che ci diamo qua sotto che si chiama
manches dove ripropongono effettivamente
la ricetta dei nuggets di pollo e tra
tutte quante ci sembrava quella un
pochino più [ __ ] prendiamo 450
grammi di pollo viola a chi vai partiamo
subito ad affettare il pollo piccolini i
grandi
tagliamo un pochino a cacchio tagliare e
ti fa proprio sentire uno chef se
l'accordo in di drago scompare il dito
sotto il pollo e non so se è vero e
tutto lo stesso colore mio dito il pollo
gialle per punire i piatti
a questo punto io userò questo
l'obiettivo della candid per metterci
dietro dietro dietro mare oggi è che
quando le mani sporche non riesco a
pensare fame nera vale infatti una cosa
che io sto scoprendo cucinando con opere
di ispirazione da delle ricette
americane è la cosa più comoda piuttosto
che pesare ogni singola cosa è quella di
comprarsi questi robetti quasi risolini
per i cucchiaini suini per le tasse vi
lascio unico qua sotto perché sono molto
più comodi e semmai volete fare questa
ricetta o ricette americana in generale
io vi consiglio di averli perché sono
veramente veloci e sporchi e di meno
suggeriscono di aggiungere un cucchiaino
da tè di come lo chiami becchime la
cipolla cipolla granulare siccome io ho
messo di meta nell'inter o mezzo
cucchiaino se mettessi tutto insieme
secondo me esploderebbe questo coso
invece consigli lo più aria per poter
girare detto una cazzata ma scusa con il
coperchio quel coso non c'è un coperchio
la tua bocca
allora può comprimerlo conto che
protegga lo raggiungono il sale
all'aglio che noi abbiamo trovato grazie
a dio e quindi aggiungere ma
semplicemente un cucchiaino da tè di sun
è normale e direi che può bastare perché
poi lo raggiungo un altro ancora però
secondo dieta troppo salato succede
appunto seguirete il silenzio mi sarei
meravigliato dalle risposte garai
chiudiamo ho un po di paura un po di
timore
ok questo qui qualora non lo sappiate
sia i chicken mcnuggets che tipo le
pringles hanno una pasta di polla e una
pasta di patate che poi viene fatta a
forma di patate le per questo che hanno
una consistenza diversa e buonissima
giorno farle per i negozi una volta
ci hai ragione comuni che riguardano
perfetto
togliamo questo la parentesi kenwood se
ci vuole sponsorizzare uno stanco e di
farvi pubblicità gratis il composto
viene pazzesco
l'unica vale che non si può assaggiare
il composto da per vedere se è buono o
no di sale perché tanti pia la morte se
mi raccomando quando toccate il pollo
lavatevi le mani igienizzate benissimo
le superfici teoricamente non si
dovrebbe se non sbaglio nemmeno
utilizzare il legno perché assorbente
non so perché ma da quando mi hanno
scritto su instagram questa cosa qui ho
il terrore prendiamo delle taglie le
fonti diamo con della carta e foderà le
cose dovrei tagliarle no
se mi ha detto no pure dagli altri mamma
mia che bello trovare modi per non fare
niente
cioè avere una mappa la verità è che
taglia meglio la punta non so perché
prendete una bacinella d'acqua vi
togliete gli anelli di bagnate di vita
dovete formare tipo the chicken
mcnuggets nudi e quanto incide mcnuggets
che come sarebbe bello avere un fratello
che mi desse una mano adesso a fare
questa cosa più velocemente se solo non
fosse così impegnato a fare una ripresa
comunque risulteranno noiosa senti sto
per fare delle delle tegole enrico
perché no e volgare e faccio una forma
di cuore
l'unica palla dove li congelare perché
tutto quello che non riesco a preparare
non riesco a congelarlo non congelandolo
non lo non lo creò non lo creò non lo
mangia il ceto abbia una volta finito il
procedimento dovrete avere più o meno
diciamo una trentina abbondante di
nuggets che metteremo in freezer per due
ore due ore dopo i nuggets si saranno
ghiacciati e allo stesso tempo gli
ospiti di questa casa si saranno
duplicati in tra parentesi abbiamo anche
la patrona di questa casa che c'è anche
ripetuto i nomi di tutta questa gente
qui come che sono
josh johnson il piccolo franklin e bach
rubert meredith la smemorata il mal
greta smemorata giudici che ho
soprannominato io no e poi il cavaliere
iniziamo a preparare i nostri nuggets la
prima cosa importante da fare è prendere
un termometro da cucina
no giulia non è il tuo ti dà fastidio ma
è l'invidia che parla sarebbe due sonde
tre punti a utilizzare tre ciotole in
questa metteremo diciamo i nostri
ingredienti secchi in questo quelli
liquidi e poi utilizzeremo perché qui su
manches lo usano un impasto per la
tempura perché che a tutti i presenti
fondamentalmente è più soffice puoi
mangiare molti di più non lo so perché
sinceramente li seguirò speriamo che
vengano bene per la parte secca avremo
bisogno di mezza farsa
naturalmente i grammy mi rimetto qua
sotto allinfo box se volete utilizzarli
di farina e 4 cucchiai di amido di mais
per gli ingredienti invece liquidi
abbiamo un quarto di tazza di latte un
uomo come si chiama la infine
l'impanatura per la tempura una tazza di
farina che mi sembra un botto da bere
una tazza di farina e forse sì radio 3
col sorriso comunque ne succede su una
certa serietà ma non lo so un cucchiaio
di amido di mais trequarti di acqua
molto frizzante fredda questa è
frizzantissima perfetta mettete i guanti
tocca la pelle stiamo utilizzando un
termometro per monitorare il problema
con po rumoroso ecco 336 no non ho
monitorato faremo due giri di fratture
la prima a 160 gradi per un minuto e poi
un'altra a temperatura più alta
ti prego stai zitto ti prego ma perchè
soffriva lui chissà perché ho il secondo
il cuore un giro qui un giro qui
torniamo qui e poi qua ma tu sei il
moralizzatore dell'angolo delle palle
stanno venendo tranquilla cioè qui
venendo delle palle enormi la prima
frittura e questo dovrà essere pallini
quando escono cui dovrai termometro però
pensa che io sono dentro questo incubo
più di te perché sto imparando oddio
quello stesso mare perché stai dovendo
riprendere il passo nella farina poi
passò nel luogo e non mi si attacca il
nuovo sopra ti prego ti prego perché
bisogno di una emergenza
ora questi si stanno gonfiando di meno
però temo di aver fatto troppo bene da
tempo bene abbiamo finito la cottura 160
gradi che vi porterà ad avere dei
nuggets
così ci siamo resi conto che
effettivamente non nuggets è il plurale
in inglese noi stiamo parlando italiano
quindi quando tu prendi in prestito una
parola inglese dall'italiano usarla solo
al singolare quindi e nugget non sono
quanti followers hymer quanti follower
hai paura finito questo momento possiamo
parlare comunque pochi to avremo una che
così un'area psicosi
è abbastanza grosso quindi dovete farvi
ancora più piccoli ma ho capito fanno
schifo ero pronto a prendere la gente in
faccia finita questa cottura a 60 gradi
dovremo passare alla seconda cottura 375
farà knight che adesso scoprire la
quanto sono in celsius ragazzi avete
bisogno di un termometro da cucina video
messi è un pochino in descrizioni se li
volete prendere questo è ma non c'è tra
quelli a 190 gradi dovete friggere
adesso una cosa positiva di questa roba
qui e che potete prendere e buttarli
insieme perché non c'è più rischio che
si incolli in uno o l'altro questa qui è
il risultato finale
no forse è meglio non parlarne che ci ha
fatto intendere mangano 4
il diamante dell'oceano di rose
americano per tempo ai bellocco di carta
stagnola dell'oceano
lo vuole
male angolo stava bene ma da ke occhio
modesti che tutto è ok non troppo di più
ragazzi grazie
non so se ciò non so se ci assomigliano
in basso boni che schifo scusare
un secondo solo gli preferito salsa
ketchup ma bisognoso larghi alla fine
comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video è notte fuori ci
abbiamo messo i secoli per fare questa
ricetta che dire noi ci vediamo sempre
la prossima settimana di domenica alle
12 ciao